le qu'est ce que c'est tout ça
ah mais j'y suis c'est le réassortiment
de mon coeur pour les trois mois à venir
tiens une autre mademoiselle julie votre
kiosque est enfermé
j'ai déposé voces à côté pour sûr
j'espère que vous trouverez quelqu'un
pour vous les rentrées je pars en
promenade avec messieurs du stop signé
le facteur françois wii qui a été le
joli tu as vu les caisses sont pas ah
bah oui saint louis je les vois très
bien et tu voudrais sans doute que je
t'aide à les ranger
oui d'avantias s'il te plaît eh bien
avec plaisir julie effectivement c'est
un travailleur un petit peu pénible pour
une femme il faut la musculature d'un
homme gillett hier valérie bravo votre
douce que tu sais faire
allons-y banda pas où commencer pour que
ce soit vite et bien c'est fait tu sais
elles sont très lourdes alors je te
conseille pour tes chauffer les muscles
ne commencer par les plus petites par
les plus petites
non non ce n'est pas une bonne formule
ça julie notre jeu mais au contraire
commencer par la plus grosse parce que
comme c'est ensuite et bien les autres
me sembleront plus légère et bien au
travail admirer la technique
je me baisse avec souplesse sur les
jambes j'attrape la caisse de chaque
côté et ja soulève 2 et 3 tu as perdu
quelque chose c'est pas gentil de me
canoy julie méchant je crois que je me
suis donné un tour de ré écoute je suis
désolé repose-toi aaa
je me demande qui va m'aider à
transporter ses caisses ce que je veux
demander à casimir et refusera sûrement
pas de t d a bomb arrivait pas mou
je suis en pleine forme aujourd'hui
oui mais mes muscles sont très souples
et jeu pourra et soulever des montagnes
mais je me suis premier à moi même de ne
rien faire qu'une bonne sieste au soleil
et rien ni personne ne pourra m'empêcher
moi il ne s'est rien refusé
or qu'est ce que ça a c'est toi je lui
dis moi casimiri faut que tu viennes
mais d arranger mais qu'est ce je ne
peux pas mais pourquoi parce que c'est
impossible ça pour quelle raison aurait
bien parce que parce que je suis malade
je suis bien battu a du toupet tu viens
dire à nos amis que tu étais en pleine
forme il y a deux minutes oui mais tout
de rouge
je me sens malade c'est dommage je viens
de me promettre à moi-même que que je ne
pouvais rien faire alors je ne peux pas
faire autrement
julie si tu veux demain je pourrais mais
pas aujourd'hui je suis malade très bien
si tu es malade je vais aller chercher
le docteur c'est ça va chercher le
docteur
il très sympathique le docteur seulement
voilà il vient de partir en vacances et
son remplaçant n'est pas encore arrivé
alors je suis tranquille figure toi
françois que casimir prétend qu'il est
mal avait il ne veut pas m'aider s'il
est malade il faut aller chercher un
médecin julie à ce propos comment
va-t-on tout doha bah c'est pas encore
ça se débloque un petit peu mais c'est
c'est pas tout à fait ça on étage mois
déjà à casimir malades
ah oui mais il prétend qu'il est malade
c'est parce qu'il ne veut pas travailler
il a décidé aujourd'hui de ne rien faire
quel toupet outils et ennuyeux c'est que
le médecin est parti en vacances hier et
son remplaçant il arrive que tout à
l'heure je lis j'ai une idée d'y avoir
accès alors qu'on soit tu es prêt à
voilà docteur babychou si vous voulez
bien me suivre c'est par ici
gurrumul au fou voilà casimir il est
très malade le pogo bonjour voila
casimir est l'un des moins bons jours
que du beau jeu je suis leur place au
dunnichay je remplace certain d'arriver
je me sentais pas bien du tout vous avez
vous met à fumer ou mais voilà j'ai mal
à la le à un peu la rumeur
et puis là aussi populaire et je suis
aussi béni oui oui j'ai mal partout au
show de lumière vous savez elle perd
tout ça partout en docteur barbichette
su pourquoi ce n'est pas chez check
barbie en bande à henry fallait du temps
barbis où je me mettais au repos complet
mais pas si vite vous n'avez pas pu
résoudre la température de target
j'ai 25 de fièvre au haut niveau
mais bon d'accord alors cgt 55 c 55
quand j'ai trouvé aussi que tu marchais
contient qu'on aimait également que si
nous faisons une moyenne g37 toile à 35
je suis parti chez que je ne connais pas
malade et pourtant je me sens quand même
très très faible a déjà été très faible
la tête vous tuer le pet être eh bien je
vais vous discutez tenir un petit
appareil respirent et déchiré l'odm au
questionnaire au corps à corps oui ça va
toucher tout chez vous ça ne vaut pas
que chez moi touché 3 333 3 je ne te
crois 34 35 37 39 avant de tirer log
[Musique]
fêté la fin j'étais gay c'est grave
docteur là la machine sont régulièrement
mais il faut vous traîniez rapidement et
d'ailleurs qu'il ait pu faire une petite
horde à gauche alors que j'aime
également beaucoup de chercheurs et
porter des objets très lourd
la baie vitrée mais généreux bonis
je ne serai pas que j'étais réellement
malade tu vois casimir tu entendu ce
qu'a dit le docteur beaucoup d'exercice
et porter des choses très lourd tiens
riquet soit tu pourrais peut-être les
porter bon ben si ce seul moyen pour
guérir
allons-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et hop
ouf
et voilà tu te sens mieux convenir mieux
or alors non pas du tout au contraire
maintenant je me sens fatigué tiens pour
me remonter je vais aller me faire afin
bondoux be borg a annoncé casimir h et
injures bravo que je vois votre bonne
mine quand vous êtes tout à fait guéri
j'avais oublié de vous dire que tu as
l'air pas question de manger du
gloubiboulga 29 chine on génère shit non
au dr barbiche ou au
[Musique]